Resuelve el sistema de
ecuaciones lineales graficándolo.
Las ecuaciones que nos dan son,
"5x" más "3y" igual a 7
y "3x" menos "y" igual a 8.
Cuando nos están pidiendo
resolver el sistema,
lo que nos pidiendo en realidad es encontrar
la "x" y la "y" que satisfacen ambas ecuaciones.
Cuando nos piden
que sea graficando,
graficar esta ecuación
es dibujar los valores de "x" y "y"
que satisfacen esta ecuación
y graficar esta otra ecuación
es dibujar los valores de "x" y "y"
que satisfacen esta otra ecuación,
cuando nos piden entonces un valor de "x" y "y"
que satisface ambas ecuaciones,
ese punto debe
de estar en ambas ecuaciones
o más bien debe de estar
en las gráficas de ambas ecuaciones,
por lo cual será
la intersección de las gráficas.
Veamos si podemos hacer eso,
enfoquémonos en esta primera ecuación.
Queremos graficar entonces
"5x"
más "3y"
igual a 7.
Y hay varias maneras de hacer esto,
podríamos poner la ecuación
en la forma pendiente-ordenada
o simplemente podríamos dar valores en
una tabla para obtener los puntos de la recta,
hagamos eso,
al final de cuentas solo necesitamos
dos puntos para poder trazar la recta.
Obtengamos entonces
los valores de "x" y "y".
Cuando "x" es igual a 0,
tenemos que 5 por 0 más "3y"
es igual a 7,
déjame hacerlo por acá.
Tenemos entonces que 5 por 0
más 3 por "y"
es igual a 7,
este término se va a 0
y aquí dividimos
ambos lados entre 3,
¿y qué nos queda?
3 entre 3 es 1,
nos queda "y" igual a 7/3,
"y" igual a 7/3,
lo cual es igual a 2 enteros 1/3,
si queremos escribirlo
como número mixto.
Hagamos ahora
"y" igual a 0,
si "y" es igual a 0,
¿qué tenemos por aquí?
5 por "x"
más 3 por 0
es igual a 7,
este término
es igual a 0
y nos queda "5x" igual a 7,
dividiendo entre 5 ambos lados
obtenemos que "x" es igual a 7/5.
Entonces cuando "y" es igual a 0,
"x" es igual a 7/5 ó 1 entero 2/5.
Grafiquemos entonces estos puntos
para poder graficar esta línea
o una buena aproximación
de esta línea.
Entonces cuando "x" es igual a 0,
"y" es igual a 2 enteros 1/3,
aquí lo tenemos,
este es el punto 0, 7/3
y cuando "x" es igual a 7/5,
"y" igual a 0,
es decir cuando "x" es igual a 1 entero 2/5,
es cerca de 1.5,
aquí lo tenemos,
"y" igual a 0.
Aquí tenemos los dos puntos
y vamos entonces
a unirlos para obtener la recta,
trazamos
la recta, siempre es
un poco difícil trazar una recta,
voy a hacerla
con una línea punteada,
se va a ver
algo así como esto.
Usualmente cuando te piden resolver
un sistema de ecuaciones por graficación,
obtienes números enteros, sin embargo
vamos a hacer lo mejor que podamos
para ver dónde se intersectan
estas dos rectas.
Bien,
entonces hagamos ahora
la segunda recta.
"3x" menos "2y" es igual a 8,
voy a hacer lo mismo,
tenemos que
"3x" menos "2y" es igual a 8
y voy a encontrar también la intersección con el eje "x"
y la intersección con el eje "y".
Entonces cuando "x" es igual a 0,
¿a qué es igual "y"?
Vamos a hacerlo por acá,
3 por 0 menos "2" por "y"
es igual a 8,
este término es igual a 0,
dividiendo entre -2 ambos lados
obtenemos entonces que "y" es igual a -4,
entonces "y" es igual a -4,
hemos encontrado entonces que
la intersección con el eje "y" es en -4
y aquí tenemos el punto 0, -4.
Hagamos ahora entonces
"y" igual a 0,
cuando "y" igual a 0,
aquí lo vamos a sustituir,
¿y qué tenemos?
Que tenemos que es "3x"
este término se hace 0,
"3x" es igual a 8,
dividiendo ambos lados entre 3,
resulta
que "x" es igual a 8/3.
"x" es igual a 8/3,
vamos a graficarlo 8/3
es más o menos 2 enteros 2/3,
aquí está aproximadamente
2 enteros 2/3,
así que este es el punto 8/3, 0.
Déjame entonces graficar la recta,
lo voy a hacer lo mejor posible,
voy a usar también
una línea punteada...
aquí estoy haciendo mi mejor trabajo
para hacer esta recta...
aquí la tenemos.
Y a simple vista,
si lo calculamos a simple vista,
vemos que el punto de intersección
aquí cae en el punto 2, -1,
2 para la "x", -1 para la "y",
este es el punto,
aparentemente es una solución con números enteros
pero es a simple vista,
tenemos que verificarlo,
esto es hecho a mano,
no es tan preciso como debería de ser,
entonces hay que verificar si el punto 2, -1
que obtuvimos aquí como punto de intersección satisface estas dos ecuaciones.
Si el valor de "x" y "y" satisface ambas ecuaciones
y por lo cual está en ambas gráficas.
Sustituyendo entonces 2, -1
en esta primera ecuación,
¿qué tenemos?
5 por 2,
más 3 por -1,
esto es igual a 7,
vamos a verificar eso,
5 por 2 es 10 más 3 por -1 es -3
y esto nos da igual a 7.
Hemos verificado que este valor
es efectivamente 7,
así que 2, -1 definitivamente está
sobre esa recta o satisface esa ecuación.
Verifiquemos ahora
en la otra ecuación.
Aquí tenemos entonces
que es 3 por 2
menos 2 por -1,
¿es esto igual a 8?
Veamos, 3 por 2 es igual a 6,
-2 por -1 es 2 positivo,
¿y es esto igual a 8?
Sí, efectivamente
6 más 2 es igual a 8,
hemos obtenido entonces
que el punto 2, -1
se encuentra en ambas rectas,
es decir satisface ambas ecuaciones,
por lo cual hemos podido resolver
el sistema de ecuaciones, graficándolo.